hi my name is Ryan right and I am
Samantha Ashlee failed and I am Taylor
Bradley we're gonna watch the trailer
today for something very serious one of
the most dramatic franchises in movie
history don't smile
night at the Museum no smiling part
three ever this is one of the most
intense Ben Stiller flicks I've ever
seen oh definitely on the edge of my
seat thinking about it literally they
put you into a world of these historical
creatures people coming to life so deep
it's a deep film it is really there's so
much II learned from this you're
definitely need to gonna go in with a
glass of wine oh yeah
you'll feel smart and wear glasses even
if you don't need them and chocolate
probably tissues tissues cuz you're
gonna cry I was yeah cuz you're gonna
cry I was trying to make a pun it is
what's did you rub off on her yes what's
the tissue
you've the jerking off jokester all
right man that no let's segue into the
trailer some rude humor
no no yes looks similar no touching
stomach
this place is waking up for the first
time
Roosevelt President of the United States
I have no idea what that means charge
we're just following him that's what
being in charge means
okay
that made me really sad because of Robin
Williams because the problem William I
literally I cannot even it's not your
fault
shut up she Robin Williams is me all the
time not your fault
stop what are you guys mean Robin
Williams chips yeah I know it makes me
cry every time and she says it to me all
the time but I do it by accident
no she my real you look a little
emotional I am it is cool to see that
like it's at least like they were that
sounds like they're gonna conclude the
franchise yeah but Magic's ending this
isn't why but they still haven't be a
part of it is like that I'm happy he's a
part of it I am too and I feel like he
would want us to laugh and like enjoy
the movie but I just I have a really
hard time I have a hard time seeing I'm
not feeling sad especially since no
one's seen this before I don't know I
feel like it'll be delightful though he
was delightful you know in the first one
it's such a great character for him it's
so much fun and I think it's kind of a
beautiful thing and moving away from the
sadness of it it looks really funny it
does and I love monkeys and the cats
yeah I think you two are really digging
this movie no I would totally see it I
was like that baby I'm not watching this
movie no I think he's great and I have a
soft spot in my heart for Southern she
always said [ __ ] what
this is a kids movie and people are
watching this right I have a soft spot
in my heart in your way
heart okay first southern character tell
me tell me if you heard it please
comment if you're a child comment and
let me know if you heard him if you
heard those words it's good for one of
those words now what I'm liking too
about the trailer is I liked it when
like the thing because they hasn't done
the movies haven't done yet we're like
the creatures are coming to life in
front of the whole city and everyone's
interviewing the interaction and
everybody getting all crazy and yeah I
know I'm excited to see this movie
actually I think they're fun you know
like I never walk away like wow that was
a really moving picture but I always
walk away like with that link I feel
like I'm in a good mood right now but I
think you're missing the point
oh how moving a picture it is yes yeah
that's a pretty soon they put a lot of
work into making this movie movie a
movie movie yep and I love dinosaurs
yes and this looks fun and Ben Stiller
is great in night in the museum it's
it's gonna be fun fun yeah Ben Stiller
knows he's getting a paycheck so he's no
do a decent job okay way to be cynical
yeah that's not cynical is his truth I
feel I'm pretty sure that's how most of
the actors feel when they do this movies
no I maybe they define I feel like they
have fun yeah definitely I act I think I
would have fun too
no I'm sure they have fun but you know
I'm just saying like he's not giving us
all how do you know that yeah but have
you ever met Ben Stiller did you ever
ask him if he was giving us all a night
in the museum
I know assuming based off I've seen Ben
Stiller do other projects and then I see
him in this franchise and you know what
girls just shut the [ __ ] up for just one
[ __ ] second sorry that's sorry that
that was not me talking that was it's
not your fault
shut up is it your fault it's not yours
not your fault
together no no but it's it's a knife
fault you guys are more creepy than
they're not tugging on my heart if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and
samantha has a channel to you check that
shisn't it out Taylor and Samantha have
a company called 48 hours production you
should check it out they have a Facebook
like that page because they have a lot
of productions in mind yes we have a lot
of stuff coming up seriously it's gonna
be awesome we're gonna tell you about it
now because it's really top secret but
you should like the page and then you'll
know all the top secret information
hellish Hado gaming hey Ryan
I'm guessing that I turn a misspelled
yet you got it right love the videos man
and your sex jokes are funny to me can
you give me a shout out hellish Hado
gaming yes I can totally give you a
shout-out
it sounds satanic to me your name and
I'm not a fan of Satan what is hate Oh
Hado is it's a type of devilish bread
but it says hellish devilish bread
devilish bread gaming so he eats
devilish bread while playing games like
Grand Theft Auto 5 that involved like
killing hookers and stuff you know
lovely shout-out to you buddy Darren
Ellis solid name damn it I try to be
first on the video anyways shout-out
please
Darren Ellis yes I will give you a
shout-out you look you look intimidating
in your thumbnail it's very dark and
shadowy mysterious oh damn dude but this
is like how sexy people are born like
myself see I put a shadow over me uh
it's like the original myspace angles
they're bringing it back you look mad he
does look really mad well maybe this
will make ya happy
what will the video yeah the video and
us giving him a shout-out yeah you know
what I make you happy I'm gonna
subscribe to you right now my groceries
for subscribers I'm your first
subscriber Darren shout out to you
lobbied Aaron Ellis GF hbg can I get a
shout out because I'm a duck do you mean
dick I think he means dock dock people
have you ever heard of dr. people look
up duck people this song yeah I guess
you're a duck person good for you
ga
fijian I don't even know your name
honestly I don't know how to work off
your shoutout I hope it sounds like a
kind of science experiment that someone
does to themselves like a weight loss
program I'm GM hbg orca beam it's
probably an acronym I'm girlfriend
hibernating big guns that's exactly what
it means I bet you yeah they're gonna be
like oh my god how did he know that
girlfriend hibernating big the CIA is
now I'm going to hire you for your
decoding expertise if the CIA does see
this I would actually really like a job
guys the CIA is not real I don't really
want to work for the government
please don't hire me government I'm
really sorry it's ignore this oh my god
I kind of work for the government
oh my god my life is a lie I think we
all kind of work for the government you
know we pay taxes yeah snows a reason
not all of us pay taxes whoa don't
advertise that I do pay taxes so I'm
allowed to advertise that I have never
been this comfortable before